how's it going red my name is and
welcome to trials fusion this game is
awesome then there's what you can do
like tricks and [ __ ] which is like oh no
oh yeah you like that but go check the
game is censoring what's really going on
here don't look kids though so since I'm
pretty good at this game I wanted to try
out the hardest Maps all right here we
go baby come on
really this is not even funny man
why is my guy sounding like Homer
Simpson oh oh no oh no I can still make
it I can just climb up the ladder I'll
just climb up why am i [ __ ] why am i
men this is so [ __ ] hard man now
you're getting on my flappy bird level
and not that's not good okay I got this
I got this I got this
yeah that's [ __ ] great I think my dog
[ __ ] somewhere it smells awful
there's no seriously none yeah do front
flips that will take you somewhere in
life what has that taken anyone in life
anywhere from except maybe gymnastics
people and [ __ ] don't distract me Edgar
the only reason why I'm not completing
this is because Edgar is my dog and I
hate him
alright alright let's think this through
the only way for me to do this is if I
do a little backflip and then at the
same time I try to go back and then
we'll just try to push forward and then
at the same time I'll just keep get
accelerated and I okay this please work
go
oh this is gonna be great the hell is he
doing he's slowly lovemaking the ground
I'm gonna complete this map I really
thought that we could do it oh my god
that was it lay your okay okay easy yeah
okay
okay okay okay okay okay okay okay hi
how how them
yes
Oh oh god oh god oh god oh god are you
cereal on my Mallik man oh oh oh
don't ruin this for me
oh yes yes no this microphone smells
like pancakes man it's probably egg the
mixture of tears and Edgar's [ __ ]
whoa damn it's [ __ ] hmm come on this
is easy easy piece of [ __ ]
backstreet's back alright oh yeah come
on you cannot be serious
Yolo
I said Yolo not no no oh damn I feels
good in my jimmies I can't climb walls
I'm not a kitty cat okay I love walls
literally how is this physically
possible for the rows for the house for
the trans O's god damn Oh Rose man no
[ __ ] way no [ __ ] way
oh god damn man that is just sad I let's
go back to the easy ones look at this
one I call this one that slap that ass I
call this one that your mom's ugly it's
serious it's bothering me I think about
it at night and I can't sleep
goddamn that [ __ ] is ugly and that's
when I call yoga this one I call this
sketch of [ __ ] all right that's
pretty cool well I'm not allowed in my
suite has [ __ ] yeah a la bicycle oh
he's just going to town on his bike man
keep going he loves it
Homer he's [ __ ] crazy go Homer I Love
You Man
I don't Oh guys what that wasn't
accepted
all right I know you love the bike but
that's is way too kinky ha ha ha ha ha
ha that's exactly what I wanted to do
man yeah I'm fine yeah oh [ __ ] don't
want to go in that fan man oh god no why
day ok
oh [ __ ] what the hell is that this is
train gonna come no more homer ha ha
come on maybe bull yes yes don't let go
Bob there's a life wonderful Evan it's
best [ __ ] you could get how am I
gonna make that jump though that's Oh
got it
slap my ass oh ah ah feels good don't
say yeah if you're not gonna [ __ ]
when you touch my chili now
okay Dean Lila job laughs fun five five
five five [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] my [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
Wow okay now we're just playing games
really I can't touch the cables man man
what is life if you can't touch nice
headstand Mac really like I don't know
English enough to [ __ ] do this okay
okay now yeah that wasn't even hard man
I would oh man oh man this game so
difficult easy this game in the universe
oh [ __ ] come on oh oh god oh god oh oh
jump aah aah oh god oh god I could
actually do this shined up on a Buddha
but I but up family have an Audi lady
I'm like you let it go so that jab blah
blah better day so yeah block your net
that goes I jabbed a blob but that's a
Dublin Kinetico so yeah I'm not gonna
run out of trials man I'm not this is
not happening
you know what let's do some tricks Maps
because those are always fun FMX
oh damn and that and then this one and
then show me what you got girl yeah oh
[ __ ]
alright see more trick ones FMX are
[ __ ] man let's see do it come on baby
yeah yeah that's not a child gonna
happen oh I'm much with the bike that's
what happens when you [ __ ] your bike too
hard yeah haha [ __ ] was that I went
through the bike man you're crazy babe
I'm gonna do the tap that ass do the top
that ass top that ass there we go in
front flip don't touch me Edgar I'm
famous I love life yeah that's that's
pretty good okay I don't know how he
does it man front flap jab flip that's
what I call that baby doesn't your
always end well doc about I press hope
you enjoyed watching this episode have a
lot of fun playing this game is really
cool if you want to check it out
yourself I'll leave a link in the
description you can get it I really
recommend it's a really fun to [ __ ]
around with if anything hope you bros
enjoyed watching leave a like if you did
I really appreciate it as always it
really helps me out a lot and it helps
me do what I don't so there's a repick
brofist for your brows stay awesome
why am i [ __ ] why am i men